Alrighty, thank you guys. We're coming to the end of this year-to-date testing.
We are in October now, so we have October, November to complete, and then, yeah
, we will be wrapped up.
So we've now broken down the swing lows, so we're good to go. Still bearish.
Tuesday 1st of October, we have inflation rate for Euro at 5, already taken
swing highs.
So the M1 structure is already bearish, so if we've got internal, then it's
going to be
still very difficult to trade.
That would be the internal, so this would be a discretionary position.
So we're in 1% current balance.
M5 invert, there you go. It's a tag, it's a breakeven, that's a target.
Solid trade.
It's internal, so we need to make sure that we add that note.
This is all we are aligned. The difference is, remember, is that you can't take
a trade,
for example, if M15 is bearish like this, but the one minute is, let's say,
bullish,
and the price like that. And to change bearish, we have to take the lows.
But when you're M15 bearish, and your M1 structure is pretty much the same,
what we're testing is that we've traded internal.
So, let's take a look at the M15.
[silence]
So, bearish.
No news.
So, New York.
[silence]
M1 is bearish.
I just think it doesn't change anything.
[silence]
So, the M1 is already bearish.
And then internal.
[silence]
You could probably wait for a continuation. It's not like it needs to go
internal.
You go internal when, for example, the entire price leg is M1, but what we have
here is M1 low.
So, it's different.
[silence]
So, that becomes bearish. Eight say five. No news.
Not a huge front of that.
[silence]
It's an SM at 10.
You need to see a sweep of those highs.
[silence]
Nope.
It sweeps the highs technically, but still, I still see that as a lot of
liquidity, but let's see.
It's Friday the fourth October, which is NFP.
[silence]
So, nothing for London, which means nothing for New York.
Still bearish.
[silence]
That's a session over.
Nope.
I'd use at least this. That doesn't get tagged.
[silence]
Seventh October, no news.
Still bearish.
[silence]
That looks like a shift.
We'll see them on structure.
[silence]
And then it just comes from there.
As long as there's a pullback of this high.
Cool.
[silence]
M5 in there, if there you go.
Equal highs across here would like to see that swept.
And then that's probably a shift.
[silence]
It's good management.
It's no news.
[silence]
Again, that's a position where it counts as a loss,
but it's such a minuscule loss.
It brings the average total loss drastically down.
What I think I would recommend you doing is when you're testing
is to risk from your starting balance.
I think it'll give you a more adequate, not necessarily adequate,
because it's not a question of adequacy, I guess.
But easier read of data.
[silence]
Again, when you're trying to sell a fallen knife like this,
a kind of inverted, you want to be more -- I don't want to use the word
aggressive,
because aggressive implies irrational, in my opinion.
Just more cognizant of your trade management.
Partically break even.
It's unmegated technically, but I could see the reason.
Yeah, let's see, turn off.
Okay, that's a break even.
[silence]
Contrary to that.
Okay, that's a break even that kind of costs us.
I mean, I'm not going to be negated, but this type of trade is something you're
going to have to manage.
In your own time for me, I would still go to break even again,
because there are going to be instances where that doesn't end up kind of
helping you.
[silence]
A lot of news, heading in a moment, and then there's nothing to trade off the
back of that.
[silence]
Sometimes it happens.
It's very unlikely that I'm going to get tagged.
[silence]
I don't like that.
I feel like it's bound to get swept.
[silence]
Well, we're doing this again.
I would much rather not be sure I know this price.
It makes no sense to me.
But all of the day I decide, but that makes no sense to me.
[silence]
That obviously makes a lot more sense.
We are technically bullish.
This is a really weird set up.
It's more of a liquidity hunt set up.
But I mean we are technically bullish.
And that's technically a break.
Choose the 15th.
This is a game that never set up that I just don't like.
The swing high is technically up here now.
The target high is really weird.
It's one that definitely would need tagging for review.
I don't even care.
But I would happen to just close this trade-up break.
[silence]
Now if it was a liquidity hunt set up it would have worked well.
If it needs to get out of discretion then it will get out of discretion if we
even get tagged in.
[silence]
That's fine.
I'll take that trade in a million days in a row.
That's an actual trade that I would take.
There's a bunch of trades in here that I wish I added the feature at the
beginning flag for review.
I've traded that I just didn't like.
But hey-ho.
Something I recommend that you do in your testing.
Oh wait. M15 pro trend. Technically not.
This is all.
But for me I'll take this trade a million times in a row.
[silence]
That means a solid trade.
We have another day of this.
That's technically swing high for me. I just disagree.
We have a bunch of news but in New York session.
That's technically a swing high which I also just fundamentally disagree with.
None of that is tradable.
That's technically a change of character which again for me is just less white
for news anyway.
There you go. Now you understand.
This is the high that I said. This is the swing high.
But for me that's just like inducement.
Like I would not use that high.
Why would I not use that high?
Because that's the type of high that gets intentionally used as liquidity to
trade in the opposite direction.
Like it's so clear. Kind of pointless trying to trade off the back of that.
[silence]
Yeah building permits which I don't think is a huge deal.
Usually not maybe could be but usually not.
[silence]
I totally missed it by a minute.
Still bearish. See this is a day where I could be wrong.
But this is a day where I'm not sure if I expect the age of session high to be
taken or not.
I still haven't figured out how to test that.
Just wouldn't really make sense for it to be. At least that's my opinion.
I'm really not surprised because it just doesn't make, there's no context.
Like sweep it for what? Like this I can understand why you would sweep it.
I can understand why you would sweep it. I can understand why it would be swept
.
I can understand. I understand. I still wouldn't understand why.
But I don't understand. But yeah it's still not something that I've developed.
I don't like this also. We bearish undoubtedly that we're going to be looking
for shorts.
Twenty-second.
[silence]
We don't have news, right? No we do but it's just later.
I didn't mean to do that.
[silence]
But you don't always have to be right to make money.
Now that's technically M15 swing high. It's not really tradable.
It could trade New York.
It could trade New York but I would probably want to price trade back into here
.
There's no news apparently.
And what's the likelihood that if I trade in here, even if I cover this low, it
's like a one-to-one rest reward.
It doesn't really make sense.
It would have worked. It would have been profitable. I'm not selecting trade,
which doesn't make sense.
Why would I trade it when it's one-to-one rest reward?
I can understand sometimes it's a 3R, maybe a 2.8R. You got a stretch here, but
the context of why it could trade higher.
I understand what price could trade higher, but that doesn't constitute for
taking a one-to-one rest reward target.
And hoping that it just runs four times the risk just doesn't make sense.
[silence]
For example, that's a 3.3. I can accept the risk of that.
25th.
4. It doesn't usually have that big of an impact, though, in my opinion.
That's high F.O.
Fair enough?
[silence]
I can't really trade the back of GDP. It doesn't really make sense.
It's no target.
[silence]
Even this like this for me, it just doesn't make sense to try trading here.
Trade below these lows in here, yeah, sure.
That turns us bearish.
This is technically a swing high, I would rather use my own discretion to go
against that.
So that's not a changing character for me, unless it obviously just continues
to run up.
[silence]
This is not a swing low. I'm not sure.
There's no trade anyway, even if it was for longs.
[silence]
That's a change of character. I much prefer that, because now we're basically
from my point of view.
This is the external, and this is the internal, from objectivity.
This is also the external, but I'm seeing it as pulled back into here, and then
we get to continue.
So not just this target as a swing low, but this target as well.
It's my point of view, 29th.
I need to buy in, I'm sorry, selling above here.
[silence]
We're not doing this again.
These setups don't work. I stand firm on that belief.
Obviously, I will let the data show us, but these setups, I don't know. I don't
think they work personally.
We're also below the swing low. So I mean technically I can't trade it, because
this is the M15 swing low.
Watch now, somehow it will just ping in here and down to these lows.
Of course.
It's still technically can't trade it. It would have to be my own discretion,
but the M15 swing low gets taken.
Again, I have the opinion that this is the low, but it's also not really a
sample I like anyway.
But my personal preference of where I like to set up on is irrelevant.
We are still bearish, but I know I'm asking for a stop loss by trading this.
No confirmation. Of course I was. When said a 30th, obviously if I was going to
take it right, I would have checked beforehand about this.
A bunch of news. A bunch of news for Europe for the entire day.
Even New York has a bunch of news. That would just be a session to not be
traded most likely.
I don't think there's a stop in here anyway.
And that takes us into November.